[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain an american
teen fantasy comedy drama film called
pleasantville
spoilers ahead
watch out
and take care
at the beginning of the movie we see an
advertisement on the tv that boasts
about an old black and white tv show
called pleasantville the organizers have
conducted a pleasantville trivia contest
for a chance to win a thousand dollars
somewhere else lives a pair of twins
named david and jennifer despite being
twins the two are vastly different from
each other and have contrasting
interests
david likes to read books watch tv and
only has a few friends while jennifer
has no interest in her studies is
outgoing and spends most of her time
worrying about her looks
although the two go to the same school
they are not particularly close to each
other david is also a freak for the tv
show pleasantville pleasantville is a
black and white sitcom from the 50s
about an idealistic family called the
parkers
george his wife betty and their two
children bud and mary sue
david spends most of his night watching
the sitcom and is an expert on it he can
even recite every line from the whole
show
unlike the parker family david's family
is not so perfect his parents are
divorced and his relationship with his
sister is non-existent david plans to
watch the pleasantville marathon and
join the trivia in hopes of winning the
thousand dollars however that same night
jennifer invites her crush and the most
popular guy in the school to come over
for a movie night their mother will not
be home that day so it is the perfect
opportunity for jennifer the night comes
and jennifer and david both want to
watch different things on tv they fight
over the remote and accidentally break
it the tv cannot be turned on now just
then the doorbell rings and jennifer
rushes to fetch her crush but to her
disappointment it is a random person who
claims to be a repairman
the twins are doubtful because they
hadn't called anyone to fix the remote
that broke a few seconds ago but they
let the man in anyway he randomly starts
asking david trivia questions about
pleasantville and david answers them all
correctly the man is impressed and gives
them a heavy looking remote as the man
leaves the twins continue fighting for
the new remote and accidentally press a
button
suddenly the two are sucked into the tv
they are now in the parker's living room
dressed as people from the 50s the
shocked siblings look around and see
everything in black and white
then the same repair man appears on the
television and tells them that they are
in pleasantville david freaks out and
asks the man to let them out but the man
insists the pleasantville world is much
better than the real world they live in
it turns out that david and jennifer
have replaced bud and mary sue in the
sitcom the twins have to live their
lives from now onwards their mother on
the show betty forces them to eat a lot
as she does with her children as they
walk through the town of pleasantville
they see everyone as black and white and
acts differently from the people they
are used to
david who knows how the people in the
sitcom act has no problem adjusting to
the new environment but jennifer has no
idea what is going on
they see a group of firefighters
saving a kitten stuck in a tree the two
find out that pleasantville has no fire
as in the show the use of fire was never
shown so no one in pleasantville knows
that fire even exists
right after mary sue's love interest in
the show named skip martin passes by
jennifer sees the handsome boy and is
instantly drawn to him she has found a
reason to enjoy her stay in
pleasantville
david and jennifer even have to go to
the old-fashioned school as bud and mary
david recognizes all the characters and
helps her sister by introducing them to
her from afar he tells her to go along
with the plot of the sitcom and not
disturb the flow
jennifer as mary takes the classes in
her school and finds out that the people
there think pleasantville is the only
city in the world the road that leads
out of the town is in a circle that
leads back to the town hence the people
are oblivious to the outside world
later at recess david sees that he is
able to score every time at basketball
the team is perfect similar to their
characters in the sitcom skip approaches
david to ask him if he can take jennifer
out on a date david tells him that she
isn't ready to date yet but mary sue
going on a date with skip was on the
plot of the show so david wants jennifer
to go out with him at least once he
warns her again not to disrupt the
original plot of the show jennifer
agrees and gets ready for the date
meanwhile david goes to work at a diner
where his boss is a friendly man named
bill johnson the diner is very popular
in pleasantville and has a major role in
the sitcom jennifer and skip arrive at
the diner for their date skip is very
different from the guys jennifer is used
to dating she gets bored at the diner
and tells skip to take her to a famous
spot in the town called lover's lane as
the two set off david realizes what his
sister is trying to do he tries to stop
them but isn't successful the lover's
lane is a place where couples come to
hold hands and watch the beautiful sky
however jennifer has different plans she
starts to make out with skip who is
completely oblivious to the idea
at home bill visits david after work as
the two talk the mother betty comes into
the living room and locks eyes with bill
the two are attracted to each other
skip then drops jennifer home and sees
the color of a red rose nearby he finds
it weird because he has always only seen
it in black and white
the following day at school david
notices skip talking about his date with
jennifer to everyone from the basketball
team all of them are shocked by the
revelation the otherwise perfect
basketball team cannot score that day
jennifer has changed the nature of the
characters david asks her to keep
everything in check but she insists the
people of pleasantville need a change
because of jennifer's influence people
in the town start seeing colors bill
doesn't want to own a diner anymore and
more and more people start visiting
lovers lane the town's people including
the mayor grow suspicious of the sudden
appearance of color in the town and are
not happy about it one day betty asks
jennifer what goes on in lovers lane and
gets to know about the concept of making
love at night she touches herself while
bathing and starts seeing colors all
around but because of such changes a
tree outside the parker home bursts into
flames
nobody including the firefighters knows
what to do because they are new to the
concept of fire david instructs the
firefighters to put off the fire step by
step and manages to stop it from getting
worse he is later rewarded by the mayor
for his bravery
david's friend from school named
margaret gives him cookies as a present
to express that she likes him david has
never had a girl like him so he is over
the moon other teens asked david how he
knew about fire david introduces them to
the concept of reading books and getting
such knowledge from literature he tells
them the story of a famous novel the
adventures of huckleberry finn
the book which until now was blank
starts to fill in with words as he tells
the story the youngsters start visiting
the library often to get the knowledge
that david and jennifer have the fathers
of the town including the mayor are not
happy about the change and decide to do
something about it the mayor visits the
father george and includes him in the
founding fathers council he wants to
work with him to implement strict laws
against colored people george happily
agrees and calls betty to meet the mayor
however betty hides in the kitchen
seeing that she is turning colorful as
well david finds her crying and helps
her by applying black and white makeup
to her face
one day david brings books of old
paintings and art to the diner and shows
them to bill bill is fascinated and
discovers that he is passionate about
painting david also asks margaret out
and is happy when she agrees this is the
first time someone as attractive as
margaret has liked him when david
returns home he sees the repairman who
sent them to pleasantville on tv trying
to communicate with him the man claims
that david and jennifer have changed the
plot of the sitcom completely he wants
david to return to his own world however
david has grown used to his life in
pleasantville for the first time in his
life he feels like he belongs somewhere
so he turns the tv off refusing to go
back he then picks margaret up in his
car and takes her to lovers lane which
has turned entirely colorful thanks to
the bulk of lovers who have come here on
the other hand betty is walking around
the town when she notices bill's
paintings displayed in front of the
diner the different colors intrigue her
so she goes inside to meet him as the
two talk bill notices that betty has
become completely colored and tells her
she looks beautiful
betty melts at the comment but both of
them know they cannot take their
conversation any further
meanwhile jennifer is turning into the
complete opposite of herself from the
real world she values her studies and
doesn't spend time thinking about her
looks she even declines when skip
invites her to lover's lane at night it
starts to rain heavily the people of
pleasantville have never seen rain and
begin to panic but eventually they get
used to it and enjoy the rain when
george returns home from work he sees
that betty is no longer there to serve
him dinner he is furious and organizes
an emergency meeting with the founding
fathers all of them are mad about their
wives and children not obeying them like
they used to the next day bill and betty
wake up in his diner together when betty
returns home george tries to make her
come to the town meeting but betty
refuses she says no to her husband for
the first time in her life and asks him
to learn to cook dinner himself george
is shocked to witness his wife acting
like this the black and white people of
the town are getting more intolerant of
the colored ones the founding fathers
ban chromatic people altogether people
start to ride in the streets bill has
drawn a naked painting of betty in the
front of his diner the riots destroy the
painting and the diner too the founding
fathers also banned the reading of books
listening to loud music and using
colorful paint betty along with david
jennifer and other chromatic people help
bill clean up the mess caused by the
riot david stands up as the leader of
the colored people and promises to grant
equal freedom to them he and bill paint
a meaningful painting on a wall as a
silent protest but the two are then
arrested for the deed
at the hearing david and bill tell the
townspeople about how everyone deserves
freedom and equality their message
touches everyone's heart and suddenly
everyone in the court starts to turn
colorful david shows the mayor a mirror
to show him that he has turned colorful
as well the entire town of pleasantville
has color now eventually they start to
progress from their orthodox thoughts
and look at the new way of living life
the circular road that led to
pleasantville now connects it with other
towns connecting the people with the
rest of the world after david's work is
done he plans to return to his own world
but jennifer has formed a strong
connection with the place so she decides
to stay david uses the same remote that
brought him there to go back home when
he finally reaches home he finds his
mother crying about her ruined life and
her relationship with his father now
that david has been through so much in
pleasantville he tells his mother that
life isn't perfect a clip of
pleasantville shows us that the people
there are much happier in color than
they were in black and white george and
betty are sitting on a park bench he
asks her what might happen next and
betty replies that she doesn't know as
the camera pants towards george we see
he has changed into bill
the movie gives us a beautiful message
that life without ups and downs is
stable but boring unlike the black and
white pleasantville our life is colorful
and has a lot of difficulties but that
is what makes it meaningful and
memorable
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching